[Applause]
even before the pandemic rape
prosecutions were falling sharply
women like leslie not her real name are
often told by police or prosecutors that
evidence isn't strong enough
in her case even though there were two
other complainants against the alleged
perpetrator
how did they phrase it their exact words
were it's not that we don't believe you
because we do
don't feel bad but we don't think the
jury would take it to court
so the jury wouldn't believe it yeah how
did you feel
i felt frozen and my face kind of went
into my hands and i just started to cry
currently only three percent of adult
rape cases in england and wales
lead to a charge down from 13 percent
five years ago
the government says it's deeply ashamed
that victims are being failed
the rape review found the reason for the
decline includes an increase
in invasive requests for the victim's
personal data
delays in investigations and
inconsistent support for victims
kate waited three years for a trial the
cps only accepted her case
after two appeals in my letter it said
factors
included the fact that i'd sustained no
physical injuries and that there were no
witnesses
how do you feel about that how many
rapes are going to have a witness
i mean i don't have an exact figure but
off the top of my head probably not a
lot
it helps explain the shocking figures
that of 128
000 estimated rape victims a year only
43 000
report to the police resulting in only
three thousand prosecutions
and then just two thousand convictions
responding to the report the government
says it will ensure that police
investigations
switch focus from the credibility of the
victim to the behavior of the suspect
they will publish scorecards to assess
results
and if the police need to take a
victim's phone they should aim to return
it within 24 hours
currently it can take months the
government says they're also looking
to make the court process easier such as
allowing more victims to give
pre-recorded video evidence
i want all agencies
whether it's the police or the cps or
the court service to have
the interests of the victim very firmly
in mind
at every stage campaigners welcome the
changes but say
it's not enough we've seen quite a lot
of extending of pilots commitments to
consultations
not um not a lot of sort of quick
positive
um decisive action that will make a
difference swiftly
to victims and survivors the pandemic
has added problems
despite nightingale courts like this one
in nottingham being set up in hotels
there's increased disruption and delay
the day before the trial i got a phone
call to say it had been cancelled due to
the lack of court space
i was ready to get in the car and go all
packed totally geared up and ready to go
get a call saying it's been cancelled
the vast majority of cases end like
leslie's
without a jury even hearing the evidence
and the question is
are the government's changes radical
enough to make a significant difference
jason farrell sky news